[Musique]
soir les enfants pour soi pour
soi
yu
ce soir nous allons bien nous amuser
nous allons faire un jeu que tous mes
petits amis m à tout à l'heure pas trop
à tout à l'heure nous nous on les sols
l'eau hop hop hop hop hop hop hop hop
hop hop où
j'avais fait part à mon sens un banc
très je ne dirai rien t'inquiète pas
on peut entrer bon cela
où tu m'as fait peur plus tort je
m'étais bien caché tout à faire peur que
si nous jouions atoch camp oui mais en
gascogne aviaire que pensez-vous de
temps
pourquoi pas je connais de très bonne
cachette dans les forêts sous les sapins
moi je préfère les cachettes de la
roulotte il y fait moins froid tu viens
on va se cacher vient que peter
cache-toi les cieux nounours ne regarde
pas hualan et sans tricher nous les deux
yeux s'il te plaît cran voilà
je les cache mes yeux comme si je triche
un mois nounours
alors ça y est
oh ils sont tous partis ma parole
sayah
vous pouvez chercher ferme l'ours où est
il ce cheval aux
gens l'entente une ma petite pépite à où
es tu
oh c'est par là je sens que c'est par là
la voilà 1 2 et 3 j'ai attrapé pepita
wii est à présent tu va m'aider à
trouver cornichons et haddaoui
un oreiller qui bouge tout seul
voyons
où juliette à excuser moi d'avoir
interrompu votre ciel
dégagé une tu ne perd rien pour attendre
mais je vais essayer de trouver tata
coucou lors du show
c'est curieux tout bouge dans cette
roulotte du coussin les pelotes de laine
voyons de la laine encore de laval hors
du champ je t'ai trouvée
c'était pas une gâchette facile dans les
champs maintenant
je trouve que tu adores il n'est plus à
sa fenêtre ou petits de aa à talloires
tort à aa j'avais simplement changer de
fenêtre à présent c'est à moi compté
jusqu'à 3 une nounours sera retrouve à
1 2 3 ou éthique gros malin
ce qu'a trouvé nous donnons notre langue
au chat
alors allez vous donnez votre langue au
chat
[Musique]
allo je suis sur mon nuage
je vous dis bonne onu
allez vite vous coucher les enfants est
fait de bois
[Musique]